[Music]
Silicon Valley Bank's sudden collapse
sent shockwaves through the financial
system prompting Regulators to take
control of the bank in order to stem
Fallout from the Panic no way
the series of events that followed the
bank failure roiled Global markets
sparked Federal investigations and is
forcing the Federal Reserve to rethink
the next steps in its inflation fight
wsj markets reporter gunjin Banerjee
explains how the week unfolded
as worries of Bank runs spread on Sunday
Federal Regulators took control of a
second Bank signature making it the
third largest U.S bank failure Ever
After Washington Mutual and svb
Regulators said customers of both Banks
would be able to get all of their money
back we are concerned about depositors
and are focused on trying to meet their
needs they were trying to bring
stability to the financial system at a
time when people were worried about will
these bank failures Ripple throughout
the entire U.S economy Regulators
created a new lending program for banks
called the bank term funding program
which allows Banks to take advances from
the FED to meet customer withdrawals we
saw the stock market the stock futures
rise on Sunday but a lot of that
enthusiasm quickly disappeared Monday
morning President Biden sought to
restore confidence in the financial
system during a televised address before
U.S markets opened thanks to the quick
action my Administration over the past
few days mayor Americans can have
confidence that the banking system is
safe shares of First Republic Bank
plunged and other Regional Bank stocks
suffered their largest decline in three
years as Wall Street scrambled to assess
the likelihood of further Fallout people
were worried will the stress that we saw
at celcon Valley Bank or Signature Bank
will that spread to other Regional banks
on Tuesday the labor Department's
Consumer Price Index showed that
inflation eased in February but still
remained high at six percent this
underscored the challenges facing the
FED as it balances stabilizing the
banking industry while also fighting
Rising prices
the same day the Wall Street Journal
reported that the justice department and
the Securities and Exchange Commission
are investigating the collapse of svb in
separate probes one thing in particular
that they're looking at is executive
stock sales ahead of the bank failure
Swiss Bank Credit Suisse and other
European Banks saw it shares hit lows on
Wednesday as worries about the financial
system spread across the Atlantic so now
people are wondering how bad is this
going to get is it going to spread
across the globe and that was really the
worry throughout the week in the U.S
First Republic stock tumbled as well as
its credit rating when s p Global
ratings downgraded it to junk status
citing its elevated risk of deposit
outflows and profitability measures
after Credit Suisse said it would borrow
up to 53 billion dollars from the Swiss
Central Bank to shore up its liquidity
shares of the troubled Bank rose on
Thursday First Republic shares also
turned positive as 11 banks swooped in
to rescue the beleaguered lender with a
30 billion dollar Financial Lifeline
they don't want first Republic's pain to
spread to the broader economy to spread
throughout the entire Financial system
because that that's not good for for JP
Morgan that's not good for Bank of
America and it may not be good for U.S
consumers treasury secretary Janet
Yellen who was in discussion with bank
Executives about that deal told
lawmakers that the U.S financial system
remains healthy I can reassure the
members of the committee that our
banking system is sound and that
Americans can feel confident that their
deposits will be there when they need
them on Friday Silicon Valley Bank's
parent company filed for bankruptcy the
largest stemming from a bank failure
since Washington Mutual in 2008. now
there's going to be a court supervised
process to find owners of the parts of
svb financials business that aren't
Silicon Valley Banks and Silicon Valley
Bank is already under Federal control
questions hung over the economic outlook
before svb failed now volatility at
other lenders is testing banking
business and consumer confidence people
were so worried about a recession going
into this year people have been
wondering what's going to crack as the
Federal Reserve starts raising interest
rates but I can tell you no one saw this
coming